le toit du monde 8848 m depuis bientôt
un siècle
c'est le défi ultime des alpinistes la
première expédition on remonte à 1922
mais il faudra attendre 1953 pour que le
sommet soit enfin edmund hillary et
tenzing norgay seul au plus près des
cieux cette semaine ils étaient un peu
plus nombreux au moins 320 personnes à
la queue leu leu
un embouteillage mortel à la proche du
sommet huit morts en huit jours sur les
pentes de la plus haute montagne du
monde
au total plus de 300 victimes depuis
la vaste majorité ces 30 dernières
années et les corps des parfois trop
dangereux de redescendre deviennent des
repères
on l'appelle green booth bottes vertes
ou ceux qui grimpent par la face nord
doivent passer devant son corps figé en
position pour relever le défi ultime
il faut donc accepter le risque ultime
oui nous avons perdu un ami explique la
première africaine noire avoir atteint
le sommet cette semaine
ça donne un goût amer à notre sentiment
de fiat
environ 5000 personnes ont gravi
l'everest un peu plus de 10 % sont des
femmes et 2 main suffisent pour compter
le nombre de québécois à avoir posé le
pied sur le toit du monde ici mathieu
prostré du canada montréal